but here's one of the fundamental things
i think people need to understand about
what liz cheney is doing is we have a
separation of powers the legislative
branch writes the laws the executive
branch carries them out and the
judiciary makes decisions uh you know
from criminal law to criminal cases to
deciding you know disputes between
neighbors
what this commission has done is taken
on the role of all of them but most
importantly this january 6 commission is
acting as the prosecutor they're
presenting evidence to themselves as the
judiciary
and then they're
they are going to be making the decision
as the jury
so they have actually subsumed in
themselves all aspects of decision
making they will decide what evidence
comes in and if it doesn't fit their
narrative we'll never see it it'll never
see the light of day
i'm dave rubin and joining me today is a
u.s congressional candidate for
wyoming's at-large district harriet
hageman welcome to the reuben report
thank you so much for having me dave
it's wonderful to be here
i'm glad to have you because we met
briefly about two weeks ago at a
fundraiser at peter thiel's house and
you were going to give a talk and then
unfortunately sometimes it does rain
here in miami and it started to rain so
you had to cut your talk just a bit
short but i thought there's something
interesting this lady's up to something
i liked what you started talking about
you're running against liz cheney
there's a lot there
so i thought first off how about you
just introduce yourself uh to the people
since uh you know wyoming obviously a
small state but an important one but for
the people that don't know you
well i appreciate that opportunity yes i
was going to give a bit more background
about who i was it was a wonderful event
at peter's home and so many of the
people there had never met me before so
i wanted to give them just a bit of
background so that they knew who they
were supporting and why we oftentimes
focus on the fact that i'm running
against liz cheney but i'm not just
running against liz cheney i'm running
for wyoming i have deep deep roots in
wyoming i my great grandfather came to
wyoming in 1879 on a cattle trail north
from texas and he ended up ranching
there for
many many years and so i have lots of
cousins i have a very large family here
in wyoming and then i come from a large
family myself when i was born i was my
parents fifth child uh when they brought
me home from the hospital my oldest
sister was five years old
and they had just bought a ranch they
were over two hundred thousand dollars
in debt they had 35 dollars in the bank
and it was 1962. so we were we were land
rich i guess you'd say but awfully cash
poor i grew up on that ranch i grew up
fixing fence and moving cows and
flipping bales and doing whatever was
necessary we all learned to drive when
we were about four years old because we
helped our dad when he was feeding cows
we were very actively involved and our
parents ensured that we were and one of
the things that they always taught us
when we were growing up and i know that
this sounds a bit strange to some people
who don't grow up in that kind of a life
but my parents always told us that we
had we had a responsibility to keep
ourselves alive from the time we were
very very young three and four years old
we were told we had to keep ourselves
alive they didn't put a lot of
constraints on us we we rode horseback
uh we did things we would be gone from
the house you know for six seven hours a
day we played with snapping turtles we
had a rattlesnake that lived under the
house for a period of time we did a lot
of things out there but we but with that
we had a lot of freedom i guess is what
i'm saying and so the flip side of
freedom is responsibility and the flip
side of responsibility is freedom and
right now in this country that isn't
really the way that people view things
and i think thomas seoul recently said
it best when he said people are no
longer responsible for themselves but
they're responsible for what other
people did
even if it was a hundred years ago and i
think that that's where we're heading in
this country and i think it's a really
wrong approach and i think that that's
why my background really helps me to
understand because that freedom is
incredibly important and it's part of
why i'm running so in terms of my
background you know i'm a water and
natural resource attorney i'm a
constitutional attorney i've been
practicing law for almost 33 years and
i've been fighting for and working for
wyoming for a long long time i work and
i fight for the people who put food on
your table gas in your car or roof over
your head and they pave your highways
and so i have the credentials i have the
background i have the knowledge about
wyoming uh to be an effective
congresswoman for the state but also you
mentioned that wyoming is an important
state it's an incredibly important state
to the prosperity of this country we're
the saudi arabia of the united states
we're the largest coal producer or the
largest toronto producer uh we're one of
the top oil and gas producers in the
nation we really are in instrumental in
terms of ensuring prosperity in this
country
and so that's why it is so incredibly
important to have someone with my
background my history and my knowledge
running for this seat because i need to
do it for wyoming and i also need to do
it for our country
you know it's funny you said it quite
well there but when i was listening to
you talk at peter's i was thinking this
is really something cause you were
saying a little bit about your bio and
i'm thinking here i am i'm brooklyn born
lived in new york city most of my life
then los angeles for you know the last
eight years until i moved here to the
free state of florida and yet the things
that you're talking about right now are
exactly the things that resonate with me
and that shows you how the ideas of
freedom and liberty and all of that
crazy stuff really has nothing to do
with geography people just don't
understand the issues so one thing that
i saw and i didn't know this until this
morning when i was doing a little
research on you that uh wyoming's
at-large district meaning there is only
one congressional district in the entire
state that that is really is that the
only state to have that i think so
i think so and we're the least populated
state in the nation so we only have 560
000 people in our state but we're the
ninth largest land wise
so i've already traveled since september
i've already driven over 13 000 miles in
the state of wyoming visiting every
single county sometimes multiple times
going to events last wednesday i was at
a bowl sale in warland and
meeting with our ranchers meeting with
our cattle producers talking to them
about the challenges associated with the
supply chain oh my goodness gracious
trying to get parts for our tractors
trying to get parts for our trucks to be
able to haul our livestock all of those
things are being impacted by this
horrific administration that we have in
place right now with joe biden nancy
pelosi and the radical democrats we feel
it in wyoming you feel it in new york
you feel it in florida we feel it
everywhere in this country because this
is a disaster that has been created in
large part because the very first thing
that that biden did when he took office
was try to choke off our energy supply
that affects me personally in wyoming
because again we're an energy producing
state but affects every single one of us
and just i've been having to eat out
quite a bit lately because i am
traveling so much the cost of food in
restaurants is absolutely skyrocketing i
had a breakfast the other day at the
airport realized it's a bit expensive at
the airport a pork chop couple of eggs a
a cup of coffee a cup of tea
um
33
now that's just astronomical
and it is because of this administration
so you mentioned that you guys are an
energy producing state obviously can you
just talk a little bit about the type of
people that are
in that line of work the people that are
in in the coal mines etc etc that are
that are doing this stuff because i
think people especially out of the
mainstream left now what you get at aoc
and the rest of them is just a complete
dismissal of these people and their
lives and the work that they do and how
you know you mentioned generational uh
how many years they've put into this and
everything else can you talk about the
types of people that are your hopeful
constituents
well absolutely they are the salt of the
earth they're independent they're tough
they know who and what we are in the
state of wyoming they understand our
constitution and they really do
understand freedom and liberty because
they live it every day
they do what they want to do and they
produce a fabulous resource so many
people want to write coal off and say
that coal is an energy of the past
that's absolutely stupid and it's stupid
for a lot of reasons one is coal is
abundant it's clean it is accessible
it's affordable uh it is absolutely an
energy of the future and we are the
largest coal producer in the nation uh
the japan china they're building
coal-fired power plants like there's no
tomorrow uh the reality is is that we
have to have fossil fuels where people
are gonna die they're gonna die in the
summer from heat they're gonna die in
the winter from cold and that's why
i'm very proud of what wyoming does
because we make everybody's lives better
when you flip on that switch there's an
awfully good chance that that
electricity is coming from my state
because it's coming from our coal so
these are great people and it is
intergenerational it's interesting
several years ago i took a tour of the
trona mines over in wyoming and trona is
uh
a
baking soda and what you use is to make
flat glass and that sort of thing and i
took a tour of that and the number of
men who followed their mothers into the
mines or followed their fathers into the
mines we don't often think of women of
being minors but in wyoming they
absolutely are they're the heavy
equipment operators uh they are very
actively involved in the industry and i
love meeting with folks like that
up in gillette
just absolutely a a wonderful area to
visit you go up there and you can see
the magnitude of what we produce in
wyoming again with our oil and gas with
our cbm cool bed methane was something
we produced a lot of earlier this this
uh this century uh and then also our
coal uh same with ranchers we're a very
independent people in wyoming what we
really want is we want
the right and the ability to make the
decisions for ourselves we don't need
the government telling us what to do we
don't need the government telling us to
put mass on our kids we we look at
what's going on with the truckers in
canada and we support them those are the
people who make sure that you have
canned goods in your grocery store that
you have meat in your grocery store
everybody in this country ought to be
supporting them and if this hadn't
become so political over all of the
coronavirus uh
hysteria we all would be supporting them
because they're standing up for what's
right they're standing up for
independence they're standing up for all
of us and i'm very very proud of them
i'm proud of the folks in the united
states who are doing the same thing i
have a nephew who's trying to get into
the trucking business and he's now
purchased two
18-wheelers and just trying to get the
parts and get delivery on things it's
about to to crush him and this is a 28
year old kid he's got three daughters
he's absolutely the most wonderful
person in the world and and here you've
got an administration that's doing
everything in their power to make it so
that he can't succeed in that business
and one of the things i often talk about
when i talk about my upbringing and and
the fact that i did come from pretty
humble beginnings is it's only in the
united states that we've always had the
freedom to succeed and we now have an
administration and a group of people who
don't want us to succeed they want to
dictate who who prospers and who does
not and that is not america that isn't
what we stand for we all have the
freedom to succeed no matter what we
came from so jumping back for a second
you know you mentioned sort of small
population uh sixth largest state
geographically uh related to the covid
situation you know everyone thinks okay
florida did it so right i'm a living
example of that that's why i moved here
people don't really talk about wyoming
related to that um what was it like in
the midst of all this because you've got
a sort of limited amount of people and a
lot of space and yet you have people in
dc telling you okay six feet mask
everybody etc etc
well you had washington dc doing it but
i'm also going to be critical of some of
the leaders right here in wyoming one of
the things that i think too many
governors did is they turned over public
policy to to uh
public health workers
and you don't ever turn up public turn
over your public policy responsibility
to a group of people that only have a
very narrow focus of everything that
they do and our governor did and so we
had some of the mass mandates we had
some of the the limiting in terms of our
schools and keeping kids out of schools
and shutting down businesses and it
shouldn't have happened in wyoming
you listen to your public health experts
but you also listen to your economists
you also listen to your small business
owners you also listen to your educators
and you also listen to your parents and
if you pick just one of those and say
okay dr fauci you're going to be the
king of all things right now as we
figure this out you're creating a
disaster and we've lived it dr fauci has
been a disaster for many reasons
including i think that what rand paul
had senator rand paul has exposed which
is an enormous amount of dishonesty
coming from that gentleman and i'm and
when we retake the house and we retake
the senate in november we're going to
investigate that gentleman we're going
to investigate what happened uh in china
and and what he was doing with with
taxpayer funds but the fact is that man
wanted to be a hero and you talk about a
god complex oh my goodness gracious that
man
really who would turn over everything to
an anthony fauci but we did we did it at
the national level and we did it at the
state level and again there isn't any
one area of expertise that should take
precedence during any type of a crisis
our economist should have had more of a
say our small business owners should
have had more of a say and i'm also
going to go back to something that's
absolutely foundational which is i don't
care what kind of a crisis you may be
facing at that particular time and
especially after two or three weeks when
we had a much better understanding of
what was going on six months even more
information our constitution exists for
a reason our first amendment rights our
second amendment rights our fourth and
fifth and fourteenth amendment rights
are absolutely sacrosanct they don't
come from government they come from god
they are natural rights they are
inherent in us there isn't a government
out there that has the right to dictate
that we cannot worship that we cannot
exercise our freedom of speech that we
cannot exercise uh you know that there
isn't due process available so that was
one of the things as a constitutional
attorney i was horrified by the
willingness of people like the governor
of new jersey who came out and said
adhering to the constitution was above
his pay grade the guy should have been
impeached right then i mean if the guy
does not recognize that his oath was to
uphold the constitution he should have
been out on his ear
and the fact that we have continued to
allow those people to to really uh you
know dictate what we can do is is pretty
shocking and hopefully it's a lesson
learned
man you're speaking my language sister i
may have to look i may have to look into
an acre somewhere in wyoming as a as a
summer home not a bad idea um but you
know i'm sure some people are watching
this going well wait dave even if it's
just an at even if it is the at-large
congressional district why are you
talking to a congressional candidate
from wyoming it seems a little obscure
from a national perspective but actually
here's the bumper sticker for this
episode you are running against a woman
by the name of liz cheney now of course
liz cheney has become a sort of star
amongst the cnn msnbc crowd as a
republican who pretty much is against
republicans and you know she obsessed
with january 6th and the quote-unquote
insurrection and everything else
so i don't want to lead you too much i
might have done it already why don't you
give me your feelings on liz cheney and
how she relates to wyoming
liz cheney betrayed our state
she betrayed our country and i'll tell
you a couple of reasons of why i say
that because i know that's a fairly bold
statement but that's why i made the
decision to run against her i i've had a
successful law practice i've been
working for a non-profit law firm out of
washington dc for a while i love the
work that i do
but
there needs to be a change and we needed
to put someone up who had the ability to
take on liz cheney and and with this
battle for wyoming and for our country
uh liz cheney there are several things
that are a problem with her including
the fact that liz cheney bought a home
in wyoming in 2012 so that she could run
for senate against mike kenzie that
imploded and she was not able to pursue
that any further and then we've heard
very little from liz cheney after that
until 2016 when our congressional seat
came open and she came back to wyoming
to run for that liz cheney lives in
washington dc that's where her family or
not washington dc excuse me northern
virginia that's where her family resides
her husband works for a law firm back
there that does work for china by the
way we can talk about that in a moment
uh liz janey has very very very few ties
to wyoming i realized that her father
represented the state of wyoming
over 30 years ago but liz cheney's had
very little in very very few ties to
wyoming and very little interest in the
state of wyoming she talks a good game
but if you scratch her what you find is
she's very very shallow she's very
shallow on the issues that are so
important to wyoming again our energy
issues are our life our
agricultural issues and then also the
regulatory issues over uh 48 of our
surface estate is owned by the federal
government and 65 percent of our
mineralist state is owned by the federal
government so we have a huge federal
footprint and the the regulations coming
out of washington d.c have been crushing
us but she hasn't done much to to
actually fix that
uh she does not represent weighing and
she isn't representing our interests as
far as the january 6th i've started
describing it this way
we have separation of powers for a
reason and i know she keeps coming back
to that you are either for the
constitution or you're from donald trump
but you can't be for both that's a
binary that makes no sense whatsoever
and especially as someone who is
actually a constitutional attorney it's
actually kind of a stupid statement and
it's a stupid statement for a lot of
reasons including that it ignores the
vast you know ignores the constitution
itself but here's one of the fundamental
things i think people need to understand
about what liz cheney is doing
is we have a separation of powers the
legislative branch writes the laws the
executive branch carries them out and
the judiciary makes decisions uh you
know from criminal law to criminal cases
to
deciding you know disputes between
neighbors
what this commission has done is taken
on the role of all of them but most
importantly this january 6 commission
is acting as the prosecutor they're
presenting evidence to themselves as the
judiciary
and then they're at they are going to be
making the decision as the jury
so they have actually subsumed in
themselves
all aspects of decision making they will
decide what evidence comes in and if it
doesn't fit their narrative we'll never
see it it'll never see the light of day
um the fact that they kept that that
nancy pelosi would probably most likely
with liz cheney's uh guidance
jim jordan out of that committee tells
you from the very beginning that there
was a narrative that they were going to
pursue and that's what they're pursuing
so liz cheney spends all of her time she
even said it a couple of days ago do we
know that that was a fact i don't
remember that specifically do we know
for sure that she was guiding pelosi in
terms of keeping jim jordan and some of
those people off the committee
i don't know that for a fact but keep in
mind how much she decides i think we
have a lot of reasons to believe it yeah
yeah i think that it's reasonable uh and
the fact that she and adam kinziger are
the only two so-called republicans on
that committee they didn't want a jim
jordan and a jim banks asking questions
about wait a minute what about security
that day why wasn't there more security
when did you know about this were there
provocateurs
in the in the crowd and who were those
provocateurs were there any fbi
informants were there fbi employees were
there other people those are the kinds
of things that are never going to be
presented as part of this commission so
what you've got is you've got a
prosecutor who is is going to ignore any
evidence that doesn't support their
narrative presenting a case to
themselves to decide
what happened on january 6th and so if
you want to talk about being you know
unconstitutional or or extra
constitutional it seems to me that this
commission is one of the very first
places to start this is a star chamber
and their intent is to come out with a
report that they can hang around the
neck of donald trump and that they can
try to ostracize and uh those of us who
support him and conservatives from now
until the end of time that's the purpose
of this we know it and that's what she
spends her time on and we're embarrassed
she's using wyoming as the
uh the launch pad to give her the power
to do that
what do you think her her true angle is
with this i mean obviously she's getting
a lot of mainstream cred right they love
her because she's sort of what i call
the pet republican she does whatever the
mainstream wants and then that's the
type of republican they like and then
the second she does something that they
don't like then they're done with her
and they pick somebody else but do you
think her angle is purely because well
perhaps what you just said uh about her
husband but also because you know her
father was the vice president there he's
so entrenched in the swamp that she's
just protecting the thing she's
protecting the dc thing
regardless of what the constituents may
be in wyoming one i can't imagine a lot
you're hearing when you're out there uh
you know a lot of people going oh this
is the most important issue of the day
number one it isn't the most important
issue for the day for people in wyoming
i think that there are democrats in
wyoming who want to continue to bang
that drum but that just further supports
the position i'm taking on this as far
as her agenda goes i think that she made
the decision in the fall of 2020 and
perhaps even before that that this was
basically a battle between her and the
president trump faction of the party she
made the decision that she was going to
go after him and around november of 2020
she was the very first especially high
up republican that called for president
trump to concede and that the election
was fine that there was no problem with
it
so it was at that point that she
realized that it was either going to be
president trump and his followers or it
was going to be her and she started
rallying the forces rallying the swamp
to try to take him out keep in mind
she's the one that organized the letter
from the secretaries of defense saying
that president trump was unfit for
office why that's really important is
that she that issue was issued what that
letter was issued prior to january 6th
it wasn't based on what happened on
january 6th i believe that they issued
that letter on january 4th
so there wasn't even anything to point
to so i think that she went all in okay
it's either trump or me and that's where
she is and i think that she thought
we're going to take him out this is the
kill shot this is going to be the end of
it and all they've done is they've
strengthened him and they've exposed
that the swamp and expose themselves for
what they are
so i don't know what her end goal is i
don't know what her long-term plans are
being from wyoming i cannot imagine why
she would do what she's doing but it
obviously has to do with the fact that
people in washington dc think very
differently than we do out here in the
real world and you know i think that
there is a certain sense of protecting
the masses back there it is a blob there
there has been created in washington d.c
uh
a sense of entitlement and a government
in and of itself that in many ways it's
not answerable to us anymore and that's
what i want to go back there and fight
against we should not be having what we
are finding out about the spying on
president trump both before the election
and after the election i
my heart hurts i am horrified that we
are finding out that the opposition that
hillary clinton and her minions and the
folks in the deep state
have been spying on the president
regardless of which party i don't care
if he were a democrat or a republican i
would be horrified by what has happened
and now we're living through this
dystopian nightmare of not knowing if we
could even trust our institutions right
now that isn't the way that i was raised
we've always trusted our institutions
and washington dc has so undermined them
that again those of us in the real world
are awfully skeptical about what's
happening back there and we're extremely
skeptical of what
cheney is doing and what her motivations
are
so how do we scale some of that stuff
back because i think you're right most
people at this point
don't believe in the institutions they
feel something has gone horrifically
awry they feel like what comes out of dc
has nothing to do with their day-to-day
life regardless of what you think of the
events of january 6 specifically
i've just never met anyone in the last
year who's really walking around saying
this is the biggest issue of the day but
they're obsessed with this stuff to sort
of keep our eye off the ball i mean what
do you think from a constitutional
perspective a legal perspective like
what can we do actually to reverse the
machine a little bit and get things back
to the way the country was supposed to
be run well one of the things that i've
been doing since i made the decision to
run for this office is i have reached
out to a variety of congressional
representatives in washington dc to
start building those relationships and
the ally ships that i'm going to need to
be an effective congresswoman back there
and one of the things that i've talked
to them repeatedly about are what my
priorities are and my priorities are
taking power out of washington dc we
need to be working with our governors
our good and effective governors the rod
ron desantis's of the world uh we need
to be working with our good and
effective attorney generals and we need
to be doing what what was intended by by
our foundational documents and that is
there should be very little power in
washington dc so even congress we have
got to start divesting ourselves but
we've really got to be divesting uh the
the unelected bureaucrats of the power
that they have and that they have
amassed over the last 10 15 years i've
been traveling the country giving a
speech called regulation without
representation and i've been exposing
what has been happening with our
administrative state and that's
primarily what i've dealt with as a as a
trial attorney so i'm a trial attorney
i've represented a lot of land owners
and business owners against the epa u.s
fish and wildlife service u.s forest
service usda all of the all of the
alphabet agencies if you will
fighting to protect our private property
rights fighting against their incredible
government overreach attempting to take
control of our irrigation infrastructure
and those sorts of things i want to take
that expertise to washington dc work
with my fellow congressional
representatives and find ways to
substantially um impact the power and
reduce the power that these agencies
have over the citizens of this country
it was never intended to be that way in
addition to which there's just such an
enormous waste associated with it you
know the epa tens of thousands of
employees yet every single state has a
department of environmental quality why
do we have tens of thousands of
employees in the epa all of whom seem to
think that their job is to punish people
rather than working with our states uh
you know our state department of
environmental quality i get along great
with the deq here in wyoming i'll tell
you what the epa and i go head to head
and i've had to have trials against him
and beat the dog out of them in order to
keep them back from you know trying to
take control of my my client's
properties um but why would the epa be
able to come into a whirling wyoming and
and start
attempting to punish people for
straightening an irrigation ditch yet
that's what they do we need to expose it
we need to roll it back we need to bring
that power back to the states where it
belongs but it's congress that's going
to have to act to do it
yeah actually can you explain that sort
of thing a little bit further because i
think a lot of people they still hear
the epa the word protections in their
environment it sort of sounds right okay
they must be nice people doing these
things as you said there's now thousands
and thousands of people that are part of
this but can you give me an example of
what type of thing would be
happening in wyoming where you know
someone is living their life as they see
fit whatever water rights they have or
whatever other natural resource it is
and what the epa would want to do
why they would claim they would want to
do it and then what happens when you get
into a fight with them well i'll tell
you i'll give you one example of a case
that i handled up in northern wyoming
and it was outside of warland where i
was last week i represented a landowner
and he moved an irrigation ditch on his
property and the epa and i know it was a
test case they came in and claimed that
he violated the clean water act by doing
that because that irrigation ditch was a
quote navigable water of the united
states it wasn't it was an irrigation
ditch he had the right to to maintain it
and to move it and do what he did
it took us six years they filed the the
enforcement action against him in 2008
we finally had a two-week trial in 2014
i'm smart enough to know that you always
get a jury trial when you're going up
against the federal government for many
reasons
but one is that the that a lot of judges
anymore are federal employees i mean
they are federal employees and they
think of themselves that way so uh i had
a jury and after a two-week jury trial
they came back and ruled in my client's
favor he affected 2.1 acres on his own
land in cleaning up what had been a
terrible disaster actually everybody had
had kind of abused that farm because it
had been leased by absentee farmers for
many years uh he took out he's an
engineer and so he designed a beautiful
uh channel through there to to make sure
that the water could flow reduce
sedimentation reduce any type of
chemigation going into the bighorn river
and that sort of thing at one point by
moving 2.1 acres by affecting 2.1 acres
on his own property he was facing
penalties of 65 million dollars because
the epa claims that they can they can
impose penalties at that time of thirty
seven thousand five hundred dollars a
day
uh that has now gone up to fifty nine
thousand dollars a day
if you violate the clean water act so
what they do is they come into these
farmers or ranchers and they say you
violated the clean water act you're
facing penalties of 59 000 a day unless
you do exactly what we tell you to do
well obviously two days you're dead
broke so nobody can fight back against
them and that's the thing is that
congress never should have given that
kind of authority to a bureaucracy
because giving a bureaucracy that kind
of punishment authority they turn into
dictators and that's what they've done
so right now i'm handling a lawsuit i
don't know if you remember when the epa
blew out the gold king mine in
southwestern colorado and they turned
the animus river orange
it was in 2015 you can google it it was
one of the worst environmental disasters
in our country's history and the epa did
it
so they went in and without my client's
permission or knowledge they built a
water treatment facility on his property
they've operated it for six and a half
years and never paid him a dime in rent
it's an unconstitutional takings that's
the kind of abuse that the epa visits
upon our landowners every day what the
epa is trying to do is they'd like to
take control of all water resources in
this country but we know what happens
when the federal government takes
control of anything especially when it
is a resource such as water that is
absolutely necessary for life you know
what happens we're seeing it with
medical care they're saying okay you
don't get the vaccine we're going to
take away your job we're going to take
away your unemployment we're going to
take away your medical care that's
exactly what they're moving on and they
have been moving on with water this is
no longer any kind of a conspiracy idea
this is truly what the federal
government does one of the most horrific
things that happened in this country was
obamacare because that's when the
federal government decided that they
could control our decision making by
controlling our access to health care
and look at what they've done to us in
the last two years they want to do the
same thing with water
i have two personal friends i tell
people all the time who were doctors
before obamacare who are no longer
doctors because they got sick of doing
paperwork so how much more do you
possibly want to know after you spent
all that money to go to medical school
and everywhere else one of the things
i've been asking a lot of my guests over
the last two months or so especially
since i've moved to florida that's been
on my mind a lot
is what do you see as sort of the future
of the united states of america i mean i
think one silver lining perhaps in these
last two crazy years is that people
have started to move to states that are
more in line with their values they're
thinking about their life a little more
seriously i think there's good reasons
for that and that's what federalism is
all about i don't have to tell you
obviously um but on the other hand i
think that's very scary to people
because then it's like well what makes
us united
do you have a vision for that i mean if
if we all just go in our separate ways
and you know say the values of wyoming
will be much more similar to what i'm
living here in florida but that's going
to be very different than new york and
cali what what
what keeps us united at that point well
i i think that the constitution and our
foundational documents keep us united
but it's okay for how for people to have
different views of the world i don't
have any opposition to that i know that
there are people who disagree with me
and i'm perfectly cool with that but as
you say we can we can vote with our feet
and we can go places that are more
aligned with us politically but even if
you don't have the ability to do that
i'll tell you what my heroes right now
are the parents those parents that are
fighting back to protect their babies
from these horrible mask mandates from
the things that they've done to our
schools these people are heroes and i i
have said for a long time with the work
that i've done when i started giving my
speech regulation without representation
our debt was around 13 trillion dollars
it's now 30 trillion dollars and i've
been watching it go up and up and up we
all have but i've been watching it in
real time because i talk a lot about it
and how there's an interconnection
between what is going on in dc with
these bureaucracies with the out of
control spending with congress largely
abdicating its responsibility for
legislating and that debt and we're the
largest debt better nation in in world
history um and that trajectory has got
to change and i've said for a long time
we're going to have to really suffer
before things get better and i and i and
i feel that way and i wish it wasn't
true
i've tried to you know sound the warning
bells i've tried to tell people we can't
keep going down this road and expect
that we're going to prosper you can't
attack everything that makes you
prosperous and expect that it's still
going to be there when you need it to
continue that prosperity yet that's
where we are you know we've got the
socialists saying we've got to take over
our energy companies and do this and
that yeah that's not going to work well
for anybody and we all know that we all
know how that story ends
so it is a matter of people standing up
for their rights i am very optimistic
because people after what the government
has done to them at the both the state
and federal level has done to them in
the last two years we're rising up and
we're saying enough when we go back to
congress this time we're not protecting
the status quo we've got 30 to 40 years
of really bad policies that we're going
to have to roll back we're not
protecting the status quo and if the
republicans go in there and protect the
status quo we've failed
do you think that the democrats and even
sort of the the pet republicans that are
keeping this thing going as we have this
sort of breakdown of the supply chain
and crazy inflation and all of the stuff
that we've talked about
do you think they think they're doing
good i mean do you think that the people
in the administration actually believe
that they're doing the right thing as
they see all of the breakdown of basic
services and everything else
you know that's a very interesting
question what i would say about it is
that
i think that dictators in general often
think that they're doing the right thing
because they think that they're always
right
and the reality is that they aren't
that's why we have the form of
government we do it's why we have the
separation of powers why it's the
executive branch that is to carry out
the law not make the law
so i i think from that standpoint
i'm not sure that they think that
they're doing the right thing but one of
the things that you find with people who
actually believe in socialism or moving
down that type of government
they're the elitists who don't believe
that they're the ones that will have to
live under it and all we have to look at
are the mass mandates and the people who
won't wear masks uh right now all of the
they we refer to them as hypocrites i
actually don't like that word because i
don't think that it really encompasses
the
what they've done which is there's rules
for thee and not for me
and there's a lot of countries in the
world where that is how they're run and
they are not run well and it's why we
don't want to live there we are the most
prosperous the most free country in the
history of the world because we have to
all live by the rule of law we're all
supposed to live by the same rules and
if you don't want to live by those rules
then don't make them for other people
and so we now have a segment of society
and i refer to them i guess as the
elitist although i don't even think that
that encompasses it but they are the
people who think that they should tell
harriet hageman what to do pretty much
all all day every day
my own parents didn't tell me what to do
when i was three and four years old
that's what i started out this
conversation with
they let me do what i wanted to do but
they constantly talked about the
responsibility of keeping myself alive
as well
responsibility and freedom go hand in
hand what these people want to do is
take away our freedom and i i don't know
that i can always get in their head but
i think that we've got an awful lot of
examples of how their form of government
and their ideas and their ideals fail
all we have to do is look at venezuela
and venezuela is a perfect real-time
example of what happens when the
government wants to tell you every
aspect of your lives and that's why the
last two years have been so frightening
for people like you and i
because we know the government doesn't
know better than we do i've got i've got
great nieces and nephews that are five
or six years old they'll go out they'll
work all day long on horseback
and you know what those kids can take
care of themselves in a lot of ways and
they don't need nancy pelosi or joe
biden or aoc or liz cheney telling them
from washington d.c how to live their
lives they do a pretty doggone good job
of it
well i can tell you from living in miami
for a month i got plenty of venezuelan
and cuban neighbors and they know
exactly what they fled in the first
place or usually what their parents or
grandparents fled right in the first
place i'm curious backing up to to the
election specifically your election
specifically um what kind of support or
or non-support are you getting from just
sort of the main republican machine
because obviously this fight between
sort of
let's say swamp republicans or just sort
of the more mainstream republicans
whatever that is whatever phrase you
want to use versus sort of the trump
wing that that still is an internal
fight that republicans or conservatives
have to figure out
you know i think it's somewhat of an
internal fight but not one that i
necessarily acknowledge most of the time
because i still believe that most of us
believe exactly the same thing which the
the republicans need to be the party of
freedom we need to be the party of the
constitution we need to be the party of
recognizing that individuals are
responsible for themselves and it isn't
for the government to step in and
dictate everything we do we have moved
down the road of collectivism in this
country in a pretty frightening way and
all republicans need to be pushing back
against that heck democrats should be
too but
i don't know why they don't but really
the republicans in wyoming have had an
enormous amount of support and we have a
broad spectrum of republicans in wyoming
from being very liberal to being very
conservative
and i have a huge amount of support as i
travel around the state i've been
extremely pleased with how people have
reached out to me and responded to me
from a national standpoint i think the
same thing as well
i consider myself to be a conservative
but everything i've talked about today
really defines who i am and so if that's
what people think is conservative or if
they think that that's moderate however
they want to view it they can i've kind
of given you a pretty good idea of how i
view the world and how i view our
country and a lot of people are really
hungry for that message and they're
really hungry to understand that there's
someone who's willing to go back to
washington d.c and fight this battle for
them and i can tell you that i am i'm
willing to go back there and do whatever
i can to turn this ship around because
we need to we
we we have been so fortunate in our
lives we have been so fortunate in what
we've been able to do like i talked
about i came from a very very humble
beginning
and now i'm running for congress because
in the united states you have the
freedom to succeed that way
our our granddaughters our nieces our
nephews our great nieces our nephews our
children all of them have the absolute
same right that we have had to pursue
those types of of endeavors we can't
take it away from them we we owe it to
the next generation and i'm fighting for
them i'm fighting for my granddaughters
uh you know jasmine and kaylee i'm
fighting for everybody in my family i
come from a few huge family i'm fighting
for everybody in wyoming and for this
country to turn to return to really our
foundation of who we are and what has
made this country so great
harriet you're the type of politician we
need because i can tell you don't even
want to be a politician which is exactly
what the point is in the first place and
because my last question was basically
going to throw it to you to say whatever
you want give the final sales pitch but
i think you just did it right there
unless you got anything else we work
where can we send people if they want to
find out more about you hegeman for
wyoming.com there's a lot of information
and liz cheney has an awful lot of money
if anybody wants to support me and help
us out to take this message as not only
statewide but nationally and make sure
that we return people to congress or put
people in congress who are going to
fight for the everyday man because it's
the everyday man that has made this
country as great as it is so i i love
the opportunity to visit with you i hope
i can come back because you're a lot of
fun to talk to i can assure you when i
go back to washington dc i'm taking
everything that is wyoming with me and
uh i'm really looking forward to serve
the people
well i enjoy talking to you and i'm not
really kidding about maybe an acre in
wyoming for the summer so we we may have
to talk i sense you might know a real
estate agent
we would love to have you here we'd love
to have you here i'll take you up if you
watch my video ride for the brands
which is on our website and that's the
ranch that i grew up on those are my
family members that's where i come from
i think it gives you an idea of who and
what i am if you're looking for more
honest and thoughtful conversations
about politics instead of non-stop
yelling check out our politics playlist
and if you want to watch full interviews
on a variety of topics watch our full
episode playlist all right over here and
to get notified of all future videos be
sure to subscribe and click the
notification bell